today's Friday July thirty-first and
you're watching gamespot news top 5 the
show with a title so self-explanatory
that this introduction hardly seems
necessary by now you've read my name on
the lower third and that's taken care of
I guess I could tease the stories but
then I'm just going to tell you the
story so that seems a little redundant I
did tell you the date though so that's
something okay news after years of
rumors speculation hearsay gossip hints
tips suggestions whispers innuendo and
thesaurus abuse mafia 3 has been
confirmed 2k games announced on Tuesday
that this third entry in the gangland
series is in development at hangar 13
the new studio owned like 2k games by
take-two interactive there are further
rumors about the setting and a time
period but we'll have to wait until next
Wednesday August fifth or the full
reveal that's the first day of gamescom
a huge gaming convention in cologne
germany that you'll be able to see all
the latest news and trailers from right
here on gamespot we had a little spark
of that new console excitement kick up
earlier this week thanks to a square
enix announcement a flame that was
subsequently doused by a square enix
announcement during a live stream
earlier this week Square Enix said that
dragons quest 10 and Dragons quest 11
are in development for nintendo's new
console codenamed NX after everybody got
all excited square enix released a
statement saying that those titles were
merely quote in consideration for the NX
and that they had no further information
to share at the moment
a few fallout 4 stories hit this week
because everyone is super interested in
fallout 4 and dying for any information
on fallout 4 did someone say fallout 4
cool it Rob according to possess de VP
Pete Hines the game is basically done it
was by and large done before we
announced it in terms of the features
going in you're not adding new features
in may june july in the year you're
releasing you're trying to get
everything fixed and you're also trying
to manufacture a ton of hip boys because
the collectors edition sold like
hotcakes but according to heinz they've
reached factory capacity and simply
can't make any more for launch you can
plan to see plenty of pit boys on ebay
selling at a high price you know what's
great about video games when characters
you like show up in unexpected places if
you preorder WWE 2k16 you're gonna get
to play as the Terminator 2 terminators
actually one from the 1984 original
movie and one from t2 Judgment Day no
video of them in action just yet but hey
pretty cool you know what's great about
video games when characters you like
show up in unexpected places if you
bought batman arkham knight you're gonna
get to play as alfred the elderly butler
can do everything Batman can from
driving the Batmobile to punching dudes
to hanging out with the Joker to kicking
dudes to making out with Catwoman hot
now that you're all uncomfortably
aroused get out of here go figure it out
need a little new sickly off go to
gamespot com / news you need something
else I don't know google it have a great
weekend
you